okay as you've heard we are now live so
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome tonight's planning committee
meeting my name is peter richards and i
will be chairing the meeting this
evening some housekeeping i've made to
start with first of all mobile phones if
you could please turn them off at the
very least to silent i don't mind if you
need to use them provided they don't
disturb the flow of the meeting um we
aren't expecting a fire alarm tonight so
if one does go off please follow us to
the car park over the road and we will
make sure you've all been
brought out of the building safely
before we send you on your merry little
way
tonight's meeting is being live
broadcast and is being recorded for
future uh observations um and on our
youtube channel
um it is a meeting in public it is not a
public meeting so please only those
people that have registered registered
to speak will be permitted to do so at
the appropriate time i will call you
forward to one of the two desks in front
of us um on there are some hand
sanitizer gels and uh anti anti what's
it desk wipes so if you want to give the
desk or the microphone a quick wipe feel
free to do so if you want to use the
antibacterial stuff again please feel
free to do so
um i think that's in terms of
housekeeping so um introductions uh if i
may so we have olivia quinn our
committee services representative to my
immediate right we have sue mullins who
is our solicitor for this evening our
planners in no particular order are
charlotte dicks paul thompson sarah
mcpherson and online we have paul harris
and matthew neal
we also have our planning manager to my
immediate left who is emily napier emily
do you have a statement to me
i do thank you chair my role tonight is
to provide impartial advice to committee
members and assist members in their
decision taking thank you
marvelous thank you very much okay let's
get into the meeting proper so apologies
for absence please olivia
we've got apologies from councillors
foreman and kendall
marvellous thank you very much um
disclosures of interests i'm going to
kick us off if i may um so uh first of
all on the final application 2200 887
vary
i'm a member of stratford golf club
which is directly behind the property in
question but i am here with a completely
open mind so i'm entirely happy that i
can stay on and take part in that debate
um and on um the first application so um
number four item agenda number four
twenty one zero one one nine seven out
that is land off ships and road
in alderminster i have a non-pecuniary
interest that relates to donations made
by the applicant to the conservative
party between 2015 and 19 the last of
which was in june 2019.
i have sought and been granted
dispensation by the monitoring officer
full details of which are available on
uh the stratfor district website
and indeed the details were read out at
our last meeting
do we have any other disclosures council
jennings
i have the same non-pecuniary interest
as you chairman i've sought dispensation
from the monitoring officer and that's
been granted thank you very much
councillor crump next
thank you mr chairman yes i have the
same non-community interest as you
chairman i've sought dispensation from
the monitoring officer and that has been
granted
marvelous thanks very much councillor
dixon
thank you chairman i too have the same
non-procuring interests as yourself
chairman and i have sought dispensation
from the monitoring officer and that too
has been granted marvelous thank you
very much councilman mills next please
thanks mr chairman um samsung's chairman
i have uh the same non-procurement
interest as you chairman i have sought
dispensation from the emerging officer
and that has been granted thank you
thank you very much council fleming
and as per the chairman's declaration i
have a non-pecuniary interest which has
been declared
and this has been approved by the
monitoring officer so you've been
provided a dispensation by the monitor
have been provided
by the community marvelous thank you
very much councillor curtis do you have
a disclosure yes i do yes thank you i'm
again item for application 21 21-0197
land of ships and i'm a resident of
ships and i live about half a mile from
the site but this evening i'm also
speaking as a member of the old mr
parish council so i'll recuse myself
from that part of the meeting marvelous
thank you very much
uh we've only got two of you left for
completeness do you want to disclose
anything
no okay marvellous in that case let's
move on so the minutes is next um has
everyone seen the minutes they've had a
chance to look at them are you all happy
a quick show of hands and then i can
sign them afterwards yeah all good
marvelous okay now we are going to do a
slight re-jig as well on the running
order so um uh what would be uh number
five on the agenda uh is now going to be
number four that is application 21 0 2 8
7 5 ful uh on camden road ships and on
stower in line with the constitution we
have no registered speakers so we are uh
able to delegate should we so wish um
would anyone like to propose that we
delegate to councillor dixon would
anyone like second councillor edin so
propose and seconded show of hands for
those willing to delegate that is
unanimous thank you very much so we will
delegate that item
marvelous now i should have said of
course we you will notice in the update
sheet that there was an amended um
recommendation on that so we are
delegating for the amended uh on the
update sheet i'm seeing a lot of nodding
so i'm assuming you all knew that
already
marvelous
right
okay let's go to application twenty one
zero one one nine seven o ut land off
ships and road alderminster um our
presenting officer is charlotte dix
charlotte whenever you're ready it's
over to you
thank you chair
so the site is indicated on the map by
the black circle the application site is
located to the northeast of the ships
and road on the edge of the village of
older minster
the ground level rises within the site
and this slide shows
the relationship to the rest of the
village and how the existing development
sits to the west south and north of the
site
this slide shows the application site
edged in red the site is currently
approximately 2.12 hectares of a
greenfield agricultural site
the red buildings that you can see
denote listed buildings with the closest
being quince meadow to the north of the
site and tie the farmhouse to the south
so this is an outline application for
the provision of 17 south and
custom-built properties with the only
matter for consideration being accessed
vehicular access is proposed from the
shipston road through the existing
skylark road development a temporary
construction access is also proposed
along the existing field access which
runs to the south of the site and is
also taken from shipston road
the indicative master plan and design
cage say that the access roads would
create a linear form of development with
two parcels of land
either side of the spine road with an
area of public open space to the north
of the houses and a linear form of
public open space to the north east of
the development
on the higher part of the slope
so this plan shows the proposed
temporary construction access road there
is a construction exclusion zone to the
south of the proposed road and outside
of the red line
and an area with special construction
methods within the area which is shaded
in brown
excuse me
the root protection areas of the trees
can be seen and notably
and t-29 which are mentioned within the
report
so this photo is taken from skylark road
facing east you can see the proposed
greenfield land which forms part of the
site in the back of the photo at this
point here
so this photo is taken from where you
enter the site
from the fields off skylock road to the
side of number 15 skylark road
this is taken facing north as indicated
by the arrow on the map to the side
so in the
background of the photo you can see
meadow house and barn cottage and you
can also see that the ground level rises
towards the east
this photo is taken panning round so
we're now standing uh at the edge of the
site again where it meets skylark road
again we're now facing east you can see
the ground level rises towards the east
of the site and towards the rear
boundary
this photo is again panning around we're
now facing to the south east as
indicated by the arrow
you can see the edge of the farm
buildings on the right hand side of the
photo
then this photo is taken from the rear
of numbers 12 and 14 skylark road facing
south
you can see the existing trees along the
boundary with the properties on the
shipston road
so these would be adjacent to where the
temporary construction access track
would be
this photo is taken from the ships and
road looking to the existing field
access for tithe farm
you can see the existing vegetation
along the frontage and the trees on the
right hand side of the photo which would
run along the construction access road
this just taken slightly closer to the
gates that you saw in the previous photo
you can see 10 skylock road on the left
hand side and again the trees on the
right hand side which are noted in the
report
this photo is taken further along the
access road and you can see the trees
again on the right hand side including
t29
then this photo is taken from the
prophet right away to the south of the
shipston road
and close to the riverstower
the site is located beyond the line of
dwellings you can see on the shipston
road here
in this section there
so just to clarify there are updates
within the update sheet which include
revised console t responses from the
llfa and seven trends which has resulted
in the removal of suggested reason for
refusal number one which relates to
drainage
officer recommendation is to refuse the
outline application for 17 self and
custom build dwellings
in line with reason number two within
the agenda on page 20 sorry page 46 and
the revised reason for refusal within
the update sheet
thank you chair
charlotte thank you very much let's call
our first speakers of the evening who
are councillor curtis of aldermen to the
parish council and of course uh
councillor jones as well who's here to
answer questions i
believe marvelous come on forward
now council curses you know the drill so
you'll have three minutes um
one your time is up i'll give you 30
seconds before your time is up when your
time's up you can stay seated for the
questions otherwise whenever you're
ready it's over to you
members thank you for your attention and
charlotte thank you for your very
comprehensive report
objectives are concerned they had
insufficient time to examine yesterday's
update reports in sufficient detail
and feel these still fail to address the
drainage of surface water flowing from
the land rising steeply to the north of
the site
and in winter 2019 surface runoff from
this land flooded many homes in the
village causing a great deal of misery
for residents a drain was dug to reduce
the risk of further flooding which
channels water to the river style via a
ditch through a neighbouring property
and a culvert under the a3400
however the coal that gets blocked it
cannot adequately accommodate flood
water and results in regular flooding to
the property and the main road
the parish council is not against new
homes but alderman is a small local
service village with already 30 new
homes built or committed 94
of its core strategy allocation
this proposal for 17 self-build homes is
disproportionate
it does not meet local housing need does
not offer any affordable housing and
makes no contribution to local
infrastructure
the sewage system is old and cannot deal
adequately with existing flow
aldeminster and whitchurch connect the
pumping station at preston on star and
there is regular sewage flooding in
winston
we have a climate emergency and must
mitigate impact of development however
alderminster has no school
no shop nor any public services its bus
service runs less than hourly pavements
along the a3400 are too narrow to walk
or cycle on in safety so residents have
very limited sustainable transport
options
for construction traffic the applicant
proposes a narrow tree-lined farm track
barely able to accommodate large lorries
tree root protection will further reduce
the track with making it impossible for
lorries to pass and residents are
concerned about damage to valuable
wildlife habitat including mature trees
characteristic of our local landscape
half the site would be public open space
which is welcome
requiring a commuted sum well in excess
of at least 250 000 pounds secured by a
section 106 agreement
the public open space in the previous
development adjacent to this application
site has still not yet been agreed and
six years on
the district council has still failed to
enforce this section 106. 30 seconds the
application does not meet local need it
does not fully address the serious
issues of flooding and sewage it will
damage the natural environment and it
makes no contribution to local
infrastructure
it is overwhelmingly opposed by
residents alderman's parish council and
with church parish meeting
in accordance with the officer
recommendation the parish council
requests that the committee refuse this
application thank you chair thank you
members
dead on three minutes thank you very
much indeed members do we have any
questions please council mills
thank you
david a lot has been made about the
flooding uh when was the last flooding
29 2019 so if you if you look on that
that picture there um in response to the
the the surface flows that we're running
from from the hills above the site
there'd been no provision made for that
in the planning application for what we
now refer to as the old stower so in
response an emergency drain was dug
to to accommodate all the surface water
runoff
that is now
channeling through to a culvert which
goes under the a3400 and through a
neighboring property and that culvert is
blocked so we do actually have ongoing
flooding problems that haven't been
addressed through this planning
application
thank you um one more not on flooding
any consultation with the parish council
on this from the
tick box consultation yes but not not
face to face it was face to face but it
was lit service yeah it was just to do
the job of consultation
thank you
anyone else counselor dixon
thank you chairman um whilst flooding of
gardens is not desirable by any means
were any actual properties flooded yes
there were yes thank you yes and and
continue to be so thank you
council adam
just a quick one um he said it's
overwhelmingly opposed by residents i
mean have you seen any signs of any
support
no absolutely not and um i refer back to
a self-filled application in harbory
where there was actually a lot of lot of
support from self-builders this
application has had no support from
anybody within the parish or any
self-builder
anyone else before i ask one
no um
i'm going back to the flooding you said
about the culvert being blocked yeah has
it been blocked for a long time does it
get regularly maintained
we only just really discovered it was
blocked when the emergency drain was dug
to to accommodate the surface flows so
basically it's it's a problem that has
been apparent since 2019 and it hasn't
been unblocked and so it continues to
flood during normal rain it's not as if
it's heavy rainfall that makes it flood
it's it's more or less any any half a
day's worth of rain will we will get
flooding
and if
um if it were unblocked and maintained
regularly um do you think it would be
able to handle the the flooding as it is
now and with the i couldn't say because
i'm not a flood expert but all i know is
that there's a lot of disputes um it
it's it covers at least three or four
properties there's neighborhood
neighbour disputes in the unblocking of
it as well so it's not actually an easy
task to unblock which is why i assume
they haven't addressed it as part of
this drainage plan
okay understood thank you very much
members any other questions
no in that case both of you thank you
very much for your time contribution
thank you thank you for your time
and we will call forward our next
speaker on this item our final speaker
on this item is councillor fielding and
cancer fielding is uh our substitutes
ward member for this evening aren't you
good evening cancer fielding
chair thank you very much
um
as it's been introduced um
are you starting your uh your speech now
yes just so i'm clear sorry i'm going to
give you the five minutes you know the
drill five minutes 30 seconds i'll press
the starter whenever you start okay
um
the reason behind this is that the
uh uh
contractor is um
the counselor o'donnell's brother and
therefore as i'm a rural
ward and she asked me to handle it
the developer i
has i believe an option on the land and
if the outline is granted it will be
sold to another developer who will
handle it as a custom-built scheme
there will be 17 plots for sale could be
17 architects designing
therefore before any approval is given
at the outline stage the council needs
to details for the construction
management plan the drainage
of both surface and foul water
the planning officer has produced a very
thorough report on the on the issues
involved and i would like to therefore
to deal with um
focus on two issues
cs4 drainage
um which both are covered under cs4
um charlotte could you put up a plan
showing the
first plan that you had
um when the star was built no allowance
was made
for drainage from the self-built field
and the old store flooded abund french
and french drain were quickly installed
along the northern boundary
this
drain
must cope with the land drainage
which are in that field
um the hill land and the runoff
from the hill the drainage is a drain is
approximately nine inches in diameter
and it runs along a track into an open
ditch which you've just been discussing
this
is however this the
have agreed to the latest scheme it does
not
cure the problem of the water coming off
the hill and the springs so therefore on
the northern side where you can see the
trees
that is now going to be have to be
have abund or similar because the hill
and the snow
will have to all run off through this
culvert even though this new scheme is
put in place
the cannot the culver cannot cope with
the water from the field plus
the water in the ditch
from the hillside
flooding will take place in this area as
shown on the plan
which is done in the
corner the
bottom corner there can can you show
that area
please
the sewage seven trent have indicated
have indicated that the sewer which
services the old store was designed to
handle this development
therefore there is no capacity to
increase
caused by this development currently the
sewage in the village is pumped under
the river store and through two villages
to preston on store sewerage works it's
50 year old and causes problems with
leaks
it appears to be
no drainage plan for the sewer
by the applicant i agree with the
officers comment with regards to cs5 and
six
these deal with the protection of trees
and landscape the temporary road that's
going to be coming down
along the
south side of that plan
um
it's only going to be there once the or
first two
years of work progressing
then all the traffic has got to go
through
skylark road
um which is narrow it is unlit it has
been built
for uh to be taken over by the dis
county council
but
there is no proper access for 17
additional properties running out
through the scheme
so
i leave it with you
gentlemen ladies and gentlemen
casa fielding thank you very much
members to have any questions for our
substitute war member please
no looks like you covered all bases
cancer building thank you very much for
your time and contribution this evening
okay um let us now move then two points
of clarification for our officers does
anyone have any questions they would
like to put to our offices
don't all jump at once
council mills thanks mr chairman yeah
this is
flooding in this culvert
it's about them
it's not regularly maintained then i
mean as
it seems to me it's always been flooding
since
adam was allowed is that that correct
so the revised train drainage plans are
actually for the um drainage from these
the application site to be taken
actually through tithe farm so into a
cult an existing culvert which is
running underneath the farm yard and
actually out into the rivers tower at a
point further upstream
um so there wouldn't be any um
excess surface water taken into the
existing culvert that's there
so sorry because i was going to ask a
similar question just so i'm clear the
the existing culver that we we're told
is blocked and i have no reason to
believe otherwise that is not part of
the draining scheme
no it is a completely separate one
um and that's what's been reviewed by
seven trend and the llfa and they're
entirely happy that it can cope uh with
the um runoff and what he needs to cope
with basically that's correct subject to
the suggested conditions in terms of the
you know detailed surface water drainage
plans they are happy with with the
outflow going to the northeast of the
site and running that way through the
farmhouse and then out um it as an
outfall into the river star at that
point okay and that's why we've moved
removed
refusal reason number one that's correct
understood thank you very much council
crump
yeah just a point question of interest
rate um in the update sheet it says a
grampian condition like somebody give me
a definition of a grampian condition
please
so this is a condition that we can
implement on
on the if if permission does is
forthcoming to make sure that the
necessary surface water drainage works
are carried out prior to the development
of the housing scheme so it's to make
sure that any necessary works to ensure
that the surface water isn't impacted on
the surrounding sites is dealt with
prior to any further works being carried
out council dixon please
thank you chairman um you mentioned this
water going to the different culverts
and you mentioned it to the north east
of the of the site
north east of my mind is uphill
is it to be pumped
so it's around this section of the site
here so um along this part of the the
site they're running along this boundary
and then through the farm
site itself
so the farm is effectively yeah further
south here um might be easier to see
so this is tile at tide farmhouse itself
and so the
the proposal is for the drainage work
the surface water drainage to come along
here and then through the farmhouse
itself and then out to an outfall under
the ships and road and then to a point
further south
and upstream from their problems that
are with the existing culvert along this
part of the um the village
it might be beneficial if you can to
show us a picture of the site an actual
picture so we can see the topography
would you ever do that please
so this is um
well this is one of the photos taken
from a sec essentially to the side of
number 15 skyline road and the arrow
shows the direction we're looking so
this is to this edge of the the site
here so it would actually run along here
and then through the farm yard itself um
and then underneath shipstand road and
then an outfall into the riverstower an
upstream point from where the existing
culvert is
okay that's helpful for me i'm assuming
it is for everyone else um does anyone
else have any questions points
clarification at this point council
fleming
um
under sdc policy it says no objection
is that because you actually don't have
a finished policy just yet or is that
because it doesn't it doesn't go against
what what what sdc is formulating is as
their policy
we actually do have some policy offices
um in the meeting at the moment so if i
can refer that question to to the policy
officers
can you point out where in the report
you're looking so i can read it i'm just
asking a question
thank you
paul you're online i don't know if you
heard that question hopefully you'll
you'll be able to answer that
yes
chair thank you
paul harris policy
seems to be getting some feedback so
uh
do forgive me
it's difficult
we can hear you loud and clear so you
carry on fine
the situation is that the site is
identified in the site allocations plan
for self-build development
and that's based on the technical work
that we produced
as evidence to support the site
allocations plan
but that's
quite a high level area of work is
called the strategic housing and
availability assessment
and that work didn't identify an
overriding
constraint to the development of the
site but it is still dependent
on at a planning application stage the
very detailed
uh evidence that comes for technical
evidence that comes forward through the
consultation process from specialist
agencies and others
which also need to go into the mix and i
think that's what
we're dealing with here the planning
policy are saying that in principle site
seems to be capable and suitable of
being to be developed
but that it is still dependent on the
planning application process to prove
that to be the case
so it
can be at the planning application stage
technical evidence which can override
the more high level work that is done in
producing a development plan for nature
of the site allocation
allocations plan
okay that help marvelous paul thank you
very much for that i appreciate it
right this time council jennings you've
got a question
let's go into the debate then council
jennings can kick us off
okay
we have a legal obligation to supply
self-built plots
um however the applicant seems to rush
this application
and there are still two material
planning reasons for refusal and in my
mind these need to be addressed first so
i'm quite happy to dive straight in
there and propose that
we go along with officer recommendation
and refuse the application
marvelous thank you very much
okay very good could you turn your
microphone off for me
uh councilmembers do you want to speak
uh stolen my thunder you know it uh it's
not a very satisfactory application uh
mr chairman so i shall go along with the
officer's recommendation thank you
marvel does anyone else want to throw
those two pennies within i'll just say
my thing now um i'm in agreement with
you there are outstanding issues that
need to be resolved um i can't say that
i'm overly excited by the drainage
scheme given what we've heard but i'm
not a drainage expert um and clearly
we've had the llfa and seven trent say
that what's been proposed is fine um so
uh i'm happy with that going uh out of
the um the refusal but the other two i
don't think we can overcome or have been
overcome
so on that basis i will be going with
the officer's recommendation unless
anyone else wants to speak um then we
will go for a vote so the proposal is to
refuse in line with the officer's
recommendation as outlined in the report
and the update sheet if i could please
have a show of hands for those in favor
of refuse unanimous job marvelous in
that case committee resolves to refuse
application 21 0-1-1 9-7 out land of
ships and road in older minster
and i will invite council curses back to
the bench please
and while councillor curtis is coming
back over we are also going to be
swapping our planning officer
where's my
so our next item is application twenty
two zero zero eight eight seven very
that is one seven nine loxley road in
stratfor upon avon our presenting
officer is sarah mcpherson sarah as soon
as your comfortable setup ready to go
the floor is yours
thank you chair this application is at
number 179
loxley road in stratford identified here
by the red line
here is the site within the wider
context of stratford and we're not
within any conservation area or other
designation
this application seeks a variation of an
extent replacement dwelling permission
granted in 2020 and since built in order
to remove the required bat loft from the
dwelling to the garden by adding a
pitched roof to an existing outbuilding
which had been erected under permitted
development
and the outbuilding is shown on this
existing and proposed site plan and you
can see that it doesn't move
position as a result of this application
it's just the addition of a pitched roof
so this is the outbuilding as was seen
under a lawful development certificate
and this is the outbuilding as is now
applied for with the addition of a
pitched roof up to a maximum ridge
height of four meters
and it would include the bat loft in the
pitched roof area
here are some pictures of the the roof
under construction at the moment from
various angles
and that you can see in the background
just beyond the fence here um is the
golf club
there's the outboarding again
and there are two updates on the update
sheet just clarifications um from the
report
and uh the recommendation stays the same
one of approval subject to conditions
thank you
so thank you very much let's call on our
first speaker for this item who is mr
elkington
good evening sir
i shall i shall give you a quick run
through so um you'll have three minutes
i'll give you 30 second warning um as
soon as you're satin comfortable there's
a button in the middle of the microphone
and if you press that it will turn red
you might want to bring the microphone
slightly closer to you
not too close because we can get
feedback can you hear that that should
be perfect fine that looks lovely um so
three minutes 30 second warning if you
could stay seated for questions
afterwards otherwise when you're ready
it's over to you okay
do you
start now yes
okay
good evening my name is barry elkington
and i'm speaking on behalf of the
neighbours of 179 loxley road
this variation is stated as asking to
vary conditions two and six of an
application first approved in 2019
ostensibly to move the batloff from the
roof of the house to above and out
building at the rear of the garden
the original description of the
development was a single detached
two-story replacement dwelling
i would rephrase this as a variation to
obtain permission by stealth for the
three-story house that has been built
and to turn a garden building into a
fully inhabitable dwelling
by doing this the owner is also seeking
to avoid the need to submit a full
planning application for a garden
structure that completely fails to meet
the permitted development guidelines
the original application for this site
in july 2019 was to demolish the
existing house and erect a building that
was over twice the size of that which it
was replacing
not surprisingly this was refused due to
its size and overbearing impact on the
neighbours
a new application was submitted and
eventually planning permission was
granted in may 2020 for a two-story
house but with the removal of all
additional permitted development rights
to avoid it being expanded to the size
of the 2019 refusal
in addition as there was a back roost in
the existing house within this grant was
a requirement for a backlog in one of
the roof voids of the new house
no sooner had this been decided that an
application was submitted for a large
flat roof outbuilding
this was less than one meter from the
boundary 181 but as the roof height was
less than two and a half meters and it
was similar to other outbuildings in the
area this application was granted
then in november 2020 a variation was
requested to quote assist in the economy
of the build of the house although quite
how it would achieve this is difficult
to see
it removed the chimney raised the roof
ridge and added two windows to the rear
sloping roof
however at this point there were no
stairs from the first floor with the bat
loft shown as occupying one half of the
roof and storage space the other
this was approved and restated all the
original conditions
unsurprisingly it was obvious from the
outset that the applicant had no
intention of adhering to these plans or
conditions
it is clearly visible from the street
that the building has been constructed
with three floors with a fixed staircase
to what should have been the loft area
which is which has been fitted out as
two rooms there is no bat loft and no
storage space
so we moved to april 2022 and this yes
another submission
this time to put a four meter high
pitched roof on the garden house for the
bats to live in
the framework for the roof has already
been erected and will require the
felling of a mature tree to put the
tiles on
30 seconds but that is not the whole
story it has been occupied as a granny
flat for most of the year and although
this appears not to be the case at the
moment it will no doubt be inhabited
again at some point
once again the architect and developer
have ignored what was approved and built
what they wanted now they come begging
for forgiveness
at the original application being for
the house as it has been built or for a
garden building of this height then it
would not or certainly not have been
granted
the planning officer's assessment that
this variation is the most appropriate
way of seeking regular regularization of
the unauthorized works is effectively
condoning the blatant ignoring of the
outcomes of the planning process and the
contempt that these people have shown
for the hard work carried out by the
planning department and yours i'm going
to have to ask you to wrap up now
because you are over your three minutes
i've got one sentence left to read i
therefore ask you to refuse this
variation and to insist that the bat
loft is cited in the house as per the
original 2019 plans and that the garden
building is reduced to the standard
height thank you mr arkansan thank you
very much you have had 15 seconds over
so i'm going to have to give that to our
board member as well but i'm sure you
won't mind that um members do we have
any questions for mr arkinson please
council mills
thank you sir um you you just said
something um it's been used as a
quantity flat has it has it got
running water and yes it's got running
water it's got a sink it's got a toilet
um it's quite habitable yeah okay
thanks all need to know thank you
okay unless there are any questions
other questions from members mr arkansas
thank you very much for your time
contribution this evening if you can
press the button in the middle just to
turn that off that'd be great thank you
very much
okay we will move to our final speaker
of the evening who is counselor fragile
speaking on behalf of councillor rolf
good evening and welcome
council francis you know the drill five
minutes 30 seconds i'll uh warning at
the end whenever you're ready floor is
yours
thank you very much um i am speaking on
behalf i'm reading on behalf of
councillor role this evening i don't
really know the history of this place so
i'll find it difficult to answer any
questions i do apologize for that before
i start to read
okay thank you um we wouldn't be here if
the applicant had put in the bat loft in
the lot in the loft of the main house
but has instead decided to build a
three-story house and therefore did not
have room for the backloft the applicant
did not have permission to build a
three-story house but built one anyway
this became an issue for enforcement
who then asked the applicant to put a
backloft in the garden building so the
applicant put in a pitched roof to a
garden room in order to put in the
backloft the outbuilding is now over
large over tall and completely out of
keeping with the surrounding area
so we have two bridges of planning
permission
one is a three-story house instead of
the agreed
approved two-story house and a garden
room with a pitched roof which is four
meters in height
this structure is over large for its
setting
and
it is understood that someone has been
living in this outer building
irrespective of it being used as a
dwelling without permission it is too
tall too large and too overbearing and
looks out of keeping
with the street scene
the applicant should be asked to remove
the pitched roof as after two years
without a bat loft i would doubt there
is any need for one now as the bats
would have moved on
it should have been done at the time
the main house was was being built
this should be refused and the applicant
be asked to remove the roof of the
outbuilding and the applicant should
also be asked to put in a retrospective
planning application for a three-story
house and follow the planning rules of
this authority
thank you
council franchisee thank you very much
well within your time
members do we have any questions for
cancer fragility
well you can ask questions doesn't mean
you answer them
i'm sure cancer fragile will give it a
good go if you've got a question do put
it and we'll see if cancer has got an
answer
if you haven't got one then stay quiet
okay no one's got any questions okay
perfect thanks rajiv thank you very much
your time contribution this evening
okay points for clarification for
officers members do we have any points
clarification council jennings first
please okay
thank you
has the height of the house changed
not a result not as a result of this
application as you'll see in the
relevant history section of the report
the height of the house was changed back
in 2021 um the roof was raised by 20
centimeters or 200 millimeters and but
that has had planning permission
thank you very much
so just so i'm clear everything that is
there with the exception of this little
pitch roof is in accordance with the
plans that have been approved by this
authority except for the internal yes
the house is built as approved apart
from the fact that the bat loft is not
within the house and that's what we're
seeking to regularize here understood
thank you casa mills thanks mr um
this bat loft was this part of the
condition then
uh yes so condition number two is our
usual plans condition and because the
bat loft was given on the plans um it is
required in that sense and then
condition number six um is a condition
requiring adherence to the
uh preliminary roosters roost assessment
um which stated that bats would be
accommodated within a bat loft so
there's two conditions which required
the bat loft to be in the um in the loft
of the house
so at the moment this has been like this
for two years looking like this
i'm not sure at which point they started
to build the roof
on the on the app building
anyone else councillor curtis thanks
um
i just could you
sarah could you clarify um
if if this
outbuilding is being
used as living accommodation
does that still come under permitted
development
um this outbuilding with the roof on it
now does not come under permitted
development so what that means is that
planning permission is required for it
doesn't automatically mean that it's
unacceptable just that permission is
required whether or not it is being used
as habitable accommodation doesn't
really have a bearing on that because
the permitted development legislation
allows for an incidental outbuilding and
that could be any sort of reason that's
incidental to your house a games room
summer house so if it didn't have the
the if you didn't have the pitched roof
um even though it's habitable it could
be it's simply the roof that makes it
yeah not committed
clarification
um
councillor rolf mentioned
um that enforcement asked for this
battle off to be put in here so firstly
is that true enforcement were involved
in the first place and secondly
um
would that be a standard kind of
mediation technique
um as with separate teams i'm not
entirely sure uh what the recommendation
of enforcement was um i would imagine
that they simply requested that the
batloff be added and this was the
solution that the applicant chose um i'm
i would
my personal view is that it i would
doubt that enforcement officers would
request a solution which uh has not got
planning permission and needs planned
permission
and so it's not likely that that'd be
their suggestion and this is just the
route that the applicant has chosen to
resolve that outstanding ish
issue yeah
yeah
council fleming
i'm not sure if i can ask this without
it sounding like a stupid question
really
but
the the bat loft that's going to go in
this this building
has ecology made any any comments about
whether it's detrimental to the bats or
whatever it being in that building
rather than being in the house roof uh
the county ecologist has been consulted
and they think that the outbuilding and
the backloft in the roof meets the
natural england requirements for new
roofs to facilities
okay council your servant
um
were the
original bats in the house roof
uh so when the bat survey was carried
out and from memory i believe there were
no
bats found at the time of the bat
surveys there was evidence that it had
been used as an intermittent roost at
some times but it wasn't considered to
be a permanent roost if i recall
correctly
and also
this two-story building has been turned
into a three-story building
this
it was a
replacement dwelling um with the primary
habitable
primary habitable accommodation across a
ground and first floor with a bat loft
in one side of the roof essentially and
a storage in the other side and then was
varied through subsequent applications
which raised the roof of the building as
i've already said by 20 centimeters and
and then it seems that since building it
the applicants have used that additional
roof space as habitable accommodation um
you know everyone is free to rejig the
internals of their house as they see fit
so that's not necessarily something that
would have needed planning permission um
but but yes it does appear that it is
now habitable accommodation but in my
personal view that's not something that
um you know requires planned permission
and hasn't been sought
so they haven't had planning permission
for living accommodation i think but
they wouldn't need it i think the other
question has been answered they would
need
cancer dixon's first
and to be honest with you councillor
dixon uh
they're more being in back gardens um
i've not gone and had a look in other
back gardens to see with it being a
a uh outbuilding in the back garden of
the house um that wasn't considered a
necessary part of the assessment to you
know see what the other outbuildings
were like in the area because it's it's
acceptable in its own right sort of
thing um and it's it's well screened
it's not got a um a particular impact on
the street scene um
yeah
council curtis
yes so that's why we're here today
because um
they got rid of the backlot that was
supposed to be in in the uh in the loft
area um and they're seeking to
regularize that via this application
that's the only outstanding matter and
that's what we're seeking to regularize
with this application
okay
have we asked all the questions we want
clarifying
i'm seeing lots of nodding so let's move
into the debate who wants to kick us off
councillor jennings
hi this is this is all about the ship
and having a putting a roof on it um i'm
not a bat expert but i'm sure the bats
wouldn't mind living somewhere and
whether it's above the shed
or not
i think it's irrelevant and i'm
struggling to see a material planning
reason to go against this and i'm happy
to recommend that we go with the officer
recommendation of grant propose that's
it
marvelous thank you very much council
curtis
thanks sir
i'm really uneasy about this um
we seem to get a number of
applications of a similar type coming
before this committee
uh we have we had one
that actually didn't come this committee
came to another committee um there were
clear breaches of the conditions to
maintain
the bats the bat loft in
the the main property they have clearly
been breached
and
i would have been happier if there had
been some enforcement on that but i
think to
grant permission for this although i
agree with catholic genetics it's in a
way it's a
relatively
minor issue
the neighbors may not feel the same and
the bats may not feel the same either
but it just seems to be yet another of
these
applications where
things have gone wrong things haven't
been enforced and the retrospective
application is trying to make good
what shouldn't have happened so i'm
afraid i would
be voting to refuse
uh thank you council curses i'm gonna
chuck in now if i may um i sympathize
with what you've said
i find it infuriating we have planning
laws for a reason
and those laws should be stuck to
however that doesn't always happen
um that's at that point enforcement get
involved we've heard that enforcement
have been involved on this and that's
why this application has come to us
there is an allowance within the
planning rules to vary and to submit
those sort of applications which is
where we're at now
we then have to consider the planning
benefits or the planning merits i should
say of
what's in front of us what is in front
of us is a pitched roof with a bat box
on a garden shed
um what's happened before
whilst
has it has some relevance we need if
we're going to refuse we have to have a
clear planning reason to not allow a
pitched roof on a garden shed with a bat
box in it
i share your frustration
but i need to be very clear that we need
playing reasons councilman
sorry i feel that clarification pleasure
cancer mill's next please yes thanks mr
chairman yeah it's
i feel very uncomfortable with this but
as you say it's uh we've got
i found it very difficult to go against
the officer's recommendation but it's
it's a little bit by stealth but
um
yeah it's it's it's not not a good one
this retrospective business is terrible
thanks
is that a second thing or are you going
to leave that for someone
you'll else about it for a bit no
problem council dixon next please
hey chairman
yes what has happened previously has
obviously gained consent
um i.e the increasing of the roof by you
know 20 million 200 millimeters to
accommodate making room space available
to for domestic use etc
so we are indeed dealing with uh a
garden shed
with a pitch roof
um
i
will second uh the recommendation that
it is granted
um it is
regrettable uh that this situation has
developed but i'd
like others
um i don't see that that we can actually
realistically enforce uh and refuse that
particular application for those grounds
but however
i would
uh think that
it should not be used for independent
living accommodation and that might be
something that enforcement might need to
look into because whilst outbuilding can
be ancillary i don't know that it should
be available for independent living
accommodation but
i'm
not sure on that one chairman
um
give me a second to think about that and
i'll see if anyone else wants to speak
councillor fleming
in view of uh my question earlier about
the ecology they're called just having
no objection to that and you know
nobody's asked the bats if they want to
move house but having said that they'll
go where they need to go so i'll be
supporting the officer's recommendation
thank you very much
if i was a bat i think i'd rather live
in the roof of a garden shed than in the
roof of a house but i'm not about so um
independent accommodation
by nature the fact that this is a garden
essentially a garden shed a pd
it's not independent from the main house
and therefore wouldn't be considered as
independent anyway
yeah
yeah so we've sort of anticipated this
arising and
it does have um a bathroom with a toilet
and a shower it does have a sink and
what appears to be a fridge freezer it
doesn't have cooking facilities doesn't
appear to have laundry facilities you
have to walk through the garden and side
access to get to it and it has no
separate parking facilities and for that
reason officers aren't concerned that it
would be used as a separate house
however we would be content if you know
to add a condition to say that it
couldn't be used as a separate house um
and that would still allow them to use
it for family or guest accommodation
would that condition be to remain
ancillary to the main dwelling yes and
not to be used as an independent value
yeah um i'd be happy with that actually
yeah
so council jennings you're happy council
dixon is the second that you're happy
does anyone else have anything they want
to say before we move to a vote
note so the proposal is to grant
application 2200 887 very uh as set out
in the officers report in the update
sheet with the addition of the ancillary
condition and non-independent property
could i please have a show of hands for
those all in favor
that's
five german and those against
one german
two german and abstentions
thank you very much um committee
therefore resolves to grant application
twenty two zero zero eight eight seven
very at 179 loxley road um as has just
been set out
members we don't have any urgent
business so we will close the meeting
there thank you very much all of you for
being here and to all our public for
attending and contributing this evening
and of course to our officers for making
it possible thank you very much
you